In this lecture you'll learn various techniques
for creating combinational logic circuits
that implement a particular functional specification.
A functional specification is part of the
static discipline we use to create the combinational
logic abstraction of a circuit.
One approach is to use natural language to
describe the operation of a device.
This approach has its pros and cons.
In its favor, natural language can convey
complicated concepts in surprisingly compact
form and it is a notation that most of us
know how to read and understand.
But, unless the words are very carefully crafted,
there may be ambiguities introduced by words
with multiple interpretations or by lack of
completeness since it's not always obvious
whether all eventualities have been dealt
with.
There are good alternatives that address the
shortcomings mentioned above.
Truth tables are a straightforward tabular
representation that specifies the values of
the outputs for each possible combination
of the digital inputs.
If a device has N digital inputs, its truth
table will have 2^N rows.
In the example shown here, the device has
3 inputs, each of which can have the value
0 or the value 1.
There are 2*2*2 = 2^3 = 8 combinations of
the three input values, so there are 8 rows
in the truth table.
It's straightforward to systematically enumerate
the 8 combinations, which makes it easy to
ensure that no combination is omitted when
building the specification.
And since the output values are specified
explicitly, there isn't much room for misinterpreting
the desired functionality!
Truth tables are an excellent choice for devices
with small numbers of inputs and outputs.
Sadly, they aren't really practical when the
devices have many inputs.
If, for example, we were describing the functionality
of a circuit to add two 32-bit numbers, there
would be 64 inputs altogether and the truth
table would need 2^64 rows.
Hmm, not sure how practical that is!
If we entered the correct output value for
a row once per second, it would take 584 billion
years to fill in the table!
Another alternative specification is to use
Boolean equations to describe how to compute
the output values from the input values using
Boolean algebra.
The operations we use are the logical operations
AND, OR, and XOR, each of which takes two
Boolean operands, and NOT which takes a single
Boolean operand.
Using the truth tables that describe these
logical operations, it's straightforward to
compute an output value from a particular
combination of input values using the sequence
of operations laid out in the equation.
Let me say a quick word about the notation
used for Boolean equations.
Input values are represented by the name of
the input, in this example one of "A", "B",
or "C".
The digital input value 0 is equivalent to
the Boolean value FALSE and the digital input
value 1 is equivalent to the Boolean value
TRUE.
The Boolean operation NOT is indicated by
a horizontal line drawn above a Boolean expression.
In this example, the first symbol following
the equal sign is a "C" with line above it,
indicating that the value of C should be inverted
before it's used in evaluating the rest of
the expression.
The Boolean operation AND is represented by
the multiplication operation using standard
mathematical notation.
Sometimes we'll use an explicit multiplication
operator - usually written as a dot between
two Boolean expressions - as shown in the
first term of the example equation.
Sometimes the AND operator is implicit as
shown in the remaining three terms of the
example equation.
The Boolean operation OR is represented by
the addition operation, always shown as a
"+" sign.
Boolean equations are useful when the device
has many inputs.
And, as we'll see, it's easy to convert a
Boolean equation into a circuit schematic.
Truth tables and Boolean equations are interchangeable.
If we have a Boolean equation for each output,
we can fill in the output columns for a row
of the truth table by evaluating the Boolean
equations using the particular combination
of input values for that row.
For example, to determine the value for Y
in the first row of the truth table, we'd
substitute the Boolean value FALSE for the
symbols A, B, and C in the equation and then
use Boolean algebra to compute the result.
We can go the other way too.
We can always convert a truth table into a
particular form of Boolean equation called
a sum-of-products.
Let's see how…
Start by looking at the truth table and answering
the question "When does Y have the value 1?"
Or, in the language of Boolean algebra: "When
is Y TRUE?".
Well, Y is TRUE when the inputs correspond
to row 2 of the truth table, OR to row 4,
OR to rows 7 OR 8.
Altogether there are 4 combinations of inputs
for which Y is TRUE.
The corresponding Boolean equation thus is
the OR for four terms, where each term is
a boolean expression which evaluates to TRUE
for a particular combination of inputs.
Row 2 of the truth table corresponds to C=0,
B=0, and A=1.
The corresponding Boolean expression is (NOT
C) AND (NOT B)
AND A, an expression that evaluates to TRUE
if and only if C is 0, B is 0, and A is 1.
The boolean expression corresponding to row
4 is (NOT C) AND B AND A.
And so on for rows 7 and 8.
The approach will always give us an expression
in the form of a sum-of-products.
"Sum" refers to the OR operations and "products"
refers to the groups of AND operations.
In this example we have the sum of four product
terms.
Our next step is to use the Boolean expression
as a recipe for constructing a circuit implementation
using combinational logic gates.
As circuit designers we'll be working with
a library of combinational logic gates, which
either is given to us by the integrated circuit
manufacturer, or which we've designed ourselves
as CMOS gates using NFET and PFET switches.
One of the simplest gates is the inverter,
which has the schematic symbol shown here.
The small circle on the output wire indicates
an inversion, a common convention used in
schematics.
We can see from its truth table that the inverter
implements the Boolean NOT function.
The AND gate outputs 1 if and only if the
A input is 1 *and* the B input is 1, hence
the name "AND".
The library will usually include AND gates
with 3 inputs, 4 inputs, etc., which produce
a 1 output if and only if all of their inputs
are 1.
The OR gate outputs 1 if the A input is 1
*or* if the B input is 1, hence the name "OR".
Again, the library will usually include OR
gates with 3 inputs, 4 inputs, etc., which
produce a 1 output when at least one of their
inputs is 1.
These are the standard schematic symbols for
AND and OR gates.
Note that the AND symbol is straight on the
input side, while the OR symbol is curved.
With a little practice, you'll find it easy
to remember which schematic symbols are which.
Now let's use these building blocks to build
a circuit that implements a sum-of-products
equation.
The structure of the circuit exactly follows
the structure of the Boolean equation.
We use inverters to perform the necessary
Boolean NOT operations.
In a sum-of-products equation the inverters
are operating on particular input values,
in this case A, B and C.
To keep the schematic easy to read we've used
a separate inverter for each of the four NOT
operations in the Boolean equation, but in
real life we might invert the C input once
to produce a NOT-C signal, then use that signal
whenever a NOT-C value is needed.
Each of the four product terms is built using
a 3-input AND gate.
And the product terms are ORed together using
a 4-input OR gate.
The final circuit has a layer of inverters,
a layer of AND gates and final OR gate.
In the next section we'll talk about how to
build AND or OR gates with many inputs from
library components with fewer inputs.
The propagation delay for a sum-of-products
circuit looks pretty short: the longest path
from inputs to outputs includes an inverter,
an AND gate and an OR gate.
Can we really implement any Boolean equation
in a circuit with a tPD of three gate delays?
Actually not, since building ANDs and ORs
with many inputs will require additional layers
of components, which will increase the propagation
delay.
We'll learn about this in the next section.
The good news is that we now have straightforward
techniques for converting a truth table to
its corresponding sum-of-products Boolean
equation, and for building a circuit that
implements that equation.